Let's go next to our caller from the eight
zero one area code who's calling today from
8 0 1.
Welcome.
Hey, David, thanks for having me.
I just want to ask you to what extent someone
tolerates religion or the religious practices
of their parents and how should you approach
conversation with your parents if you feel
like there are certain lines being crossed?
OK.
So I'm having a little bit of trouble understanding
exactly what you're saying.
The first part was to what extent should you
respect the religious views of your parents
or tolerate?
I think was the word you used.
Yep.
Tolerate.
Well, I would want to know what you mean if
ah, if you're asking do you need to be the
same religion as your parents or have the
same views?
I think the answer is clearly no.
If you're talking about do you?
Should you be respectful of your parents views
in order to maintain a friendly relationship,
then that's sort of up to you and what your
priorities are, right?
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
So what was the other part of the question?
Yeah.
So if there are certain practices that your
parents engage in, whether it's prayer or
whether it's like imposing certain beliefs.
Yeah.
In this case, it's speaking specifically like
Christianity.
How should you approach conversation with
them that their beliefs and their practices
sort of make you uncomfortable or make you
uneasy?
What would be the point?
What would be your goal in the conversation?
Let's start there.
Yeah, I guess just to be on the same page
with them, but I don't want them to say, do
you want them to stop the prayer?
And so in some settings, right, so I'll give
you an example.
My staff and I had a get together with a bunch
of different people from my family and their
family and.
At a certain point, my parents decided they
were going to pray and invite everyone to
do like a repair.
And I sort of asked them not to engage in
that, but they sort of did it anyway.
And it just seemed like any conversation I
had with them about whether or not that prayer
was going to happen wasn't productive.
Right.
And I think I had been approaching it the
wrong way.
But I wanted to get your advice.
I mean, listen here.
I've actually I know friends who have experienced
that situation.
I have some friends who the parents.
So it's a couple the parents of one of the
people are completely non-religious.
The parents of the other person in the couple
are very religious and often want when everybody
gets together, they want to do 30 minutes
of Bible study and stuff like that.
The way that it was handled there.
And I can't think of any other way to do it,
quite frankly, is that the child of the religious
parents pulled them aside and said, listen,
my spouse's family is not religious.
We want to have a nice time.
People get uncomfortable when you want to
do 30 minutes of Bible study.
And it would be better for everybody if we
skipped that.
And they they did take offense, but they accepted
it.
And there is no more Bible study when everybody
gets together.
But the thing is it that that's how one set
of people reacted.
You know, your parents may react in a different
way.
So I don't know that there's one right answer
here.
KHAJA No, that makes sense.
That sounds like a tough one.
I don't envy the position that you're in.
Yeah, no, I.
I don't imagine many people would, but I definitely
take your advice.
All right.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
If you were holding.
Don't hang up because we are going to go right
back to the phones.
It's going to feel like it's mere seconds.